a wild update now to a deadly shooting
near the airport connector roads were
shut down earlier police investigated
after someone was shot and killed
happened this afternoon near Paradise
and Russell Metro describing the scene
he came over the berm outside of
officers and that he immediately began
pointing a gun at passing traffic on
Paradise Road and it stopped the silver
vehicle that you see behind me the
driver that car was armed with his own
firearm and that person engaged him and
shot the suspect
Metro Police providing this update just
moments ago police are asking any
drivers who may have been on Paradise
Road at the time to please contact them
with any additional details that
information would be very helpful to
them